when i'm out on the way for it it feels
free like i am
able to do what i want
i'm sashay christian and i'm singapore's
number one wakeboarder
[Music]
sasha is singapore's first asian
wakeboarding champion
she started water sports at a young age
and at five years old wakeboarding
caught her eye
i went for my first big box competition
when i was 11 years old it was the asian
championships held in china and i got
third that year
in 2009 was a big year for me because i
won the asian championship so i was
asian champion for that year
and i was 16 then
growing up as a female wakeboarder most
of the people i wakeboarded with were
mostly guys you know my brother included
but that was actually really good
because they pushed me really hard
you know they didn't cut me any slack
and so because of that they made me a
better wakeboarder as well
the hardest thing about weak bodying
would be
pushing yourself when you're afraid
pushing through that fear is
one of the hardest things but also the
most rewarding thing
today sasha trained singapore's next
generation of female wake orders she's
eager to push others to succeed in the
same ways she did
one of my biggest goal for this year is
to help to grow the wakeboard scene in
singapore and to see the women keep
pushing the standard of what we have
here
it's important not to set limits for
ourselves
there's something out there you want to
do or you want to achieve
don't let anything stand in your way
there's a way to achieve that don't let
anyone else tell you otherwise
you